[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number a
hundred and ninety two of the weekly
Google cloud platform podcast my name is
Mach and just for funds I'm joined by
mark again thank you doing much hey Mark
I'm doing well how are ya I'm good just
to confuse people who are listening it's
mark and Mike always excited to come on
here and have the two marks talk about
all the cool cool cloud things actually
what I should do is I should say my name
is Mark and I should say your name is
Mark and then I use the appropriate
accent at the appropriate time I don't
think I can I don't think I have an
accent that I can switch to so quickly
like that it's the actual podcast who
are we talking to you this week well
this week we're talking to Billy
Jacobson about BigTable which is
something we have not talked about in
quite a while so yeah super interesting
to hear a little bit more about
especially for people who haven't used
it what BigTable is good for what it's
not good for how it kind of plays into
all of the different products that
Google cloud platform has great
interview with Billy as well then I have
a fun question for you wherein I asked
you if I have an organization for my GCD
project how do I break down my billing
data by folder yeah it's a surprisingly
you know it takes a little bit of extra
work to do that but it is something that
anyone who's running at GCP organization
is super interested in knowing because
well as it turns out when you pay money
you like to generally track where it's
going I guess I mean just not throwing
dollar bills everywhere just not making
it great you need to know you need to
know these things are important awesome
well why don't we get stuck into our
cool things of the week so we can talk
about all the other fun stuff that's
coming up too
[Applause]
what do you go sounds good well the
first thing I've got is our cloud run
button which is first of all it's a
button so that immediately makes it more
fun and very cool we actually talked
about this a couple of weeks ago maybe a
few months ago but now it's built into
the Google cloud official github
repositories and it's a pretty simple
it's actually pretty much just a link so
if you've got your code on github and it
either uses a build pack or its doc
arised then you can just take this quick
button put it into your github repo and
then people who are viewing that repo
can click the button and it'll just send
it right over to cloud run so you don't
need to do any additional work it's just
a really fantastic way for someone to
take your code and be like oh well I can
see the code but let me see what it
actually looks like when I run it well
just by clicking this it'll set up cloud
run on their account it'll get the code
in there it'll install it and then
you'll have that server list ready to go
oh that's sweet so if I have like a
little app or something and github I can
just push a button it'll slow on my
project and I just cloud run it gets it
you can just cloud run it and then
people can see like hey you know it's
great to see the code but let's see what
it actually does no it's very cool I've
got a fun one too by a fellow teammate
named Zeke Lagarde did an article and
has written a solution for firebase
unity solutions update game behavior
without deployment with remote config so
Remote configs a great firebase tool can
be used for mobile apps especially if
you want to be able to change out your
app behaves at runtime basically you can
change configuration values within the
firebase console and that gets
propagated out to all your applications
and you know you can be like makes this
thing bluer or rather etc this is also
great for games as well maybe you want
to change things like difficulty levels
or how many hit points are available to
certain characters in the game or if you
want to balance your play style or your
play mechanics inside your game without
having to push out whole new versions
right there's so much extra work that
has to go into pushing a new version but
if you can use remote config it sounds
like you're easily able to just say well
let's make these tiny tweaks and then
people will see those changes
instantaneously yeah so what's super
nice about this is this is a built in
directly into the unity editor you can
just pop in provide a component on to
any game object or prefab and you can
tweak how you want to basically set up
each of properties within there and
how they tie to the remote comfy
management API not only that once your
game is actually live you can actually
go back into the unity editor see the
values that are available in there and
actually upload any changes you want to
try tweaking locally up to remote config
so it gets propagated out without
actually haven't even go to the firebase
console as well so super nice thing
thank you very much for that work Dane
yeah it sounds like a really cool way
and really quick way to make those
tweaks well on the not-so gaming side
but in talking about bigquery we've
actually just launched out a new
terraform module for bigquery so if
you're into terraform and you're kind of
looking at automating deployment or
really just kind of taking your
infrastructure as code solutions and
adding in the ability to say well now we
can actually push out which tables in
bigquery which data sets in bigquery
structure out your bigquery structure
and then load in data into it all of
that is now possible through terraform
so you kind of have an open source
alternative now instead of using cloud
deployment manager you can use well
terraform to drive out what that
structure looks like and then also to
kind of make sure that you have that
backed up is code right so now you can
actually version control it nice always
good to see more stuff happening with
our form and Google cloud that makes me
very happy
finally just a nice announcement talking
about Macy's the very large retail store
is now using Google cloud to streamline
its retail operations so it is moving
its infrastructure to the cloud and
taking advantage of Google Cloud data
warehousing and analytical solutions
basically to make everything a little
bit more efficient so welcome to the
family Macy's always very cool to see
you know cases of big customers like you
know Macy's which here is certainly
known as a relatively large shopping
chain and seeing how they can streamline
it but in reality it's like there are so
many little pieces here and there that
the cloud offers to people and in
combination especially with these retail
stores that can use the hardware you
know I was actually just at the DMV the
other day and I saw that all of the
monitors everyone was using was
Chromebooks so it was super exciting to
kind of see there and then you know to
add on all the the physical layer with
the actual cloud layer I think there's
some really cool possibilities out there
definitely and lots of data what's a
date is so much data so much data
excellent well speaking of so much data
why don't we go talk to Billy all about
big tape
sounds good very happy today to have
fellow de varela Billy Jacobsen coming
all the way down from New York to come
hang out with us in the studio today how
you doing Billy I'm good thanks for
having me mark it mark absolutely do you
feel peer pressure to change her name to
mark so that you could blend in with
this table of marks what if I told you
my middle name was mark really nope to
give him entry into the marks Club I
know okay fair enough
hey before we get stuck talking about
big table which is what we're gonna talk
about today why don't you tell us a
little about yourself what do you do
here at Google
alright I've been at Google for four
years and I've actually been working on
the Google cloud platform for all four
of those years my first three years I
was working on the cloud console UI as a
front-end engineer so I have to learn
about ton of different products about
the user experience of those products
and I think Michael klandermann who was
on that team was actually just
interviewed on this podcast a few
episodes ago but now I am in developer
relations I'm a developer programs
engineer focusing on cloud BigTable
solder involves writing code samples on
the documentation creating code labs and
tutorials working on going and giving
some talks really just trying to look at
the developer experience and try to
improve that in as many ways as I see
fit so I have a question what is
BigTable because there's been big tables
been mentioned on the podcast before
right so the last episode we did was
back in 2016 with Ian Lewis so it's been
a while episode 18 so a refresher on
what big table is would be helpful
our phrasing furtively is is our
petabyte scale fully managed no sequel
database and it's really the combination
of all of those things that make it
special that you can get so big that
it's fully managing that and it's no
sequel which kind of ends up being part
of the reason it can be so big right and
so that sounds like it could be used for
anything but I'm willing to bet that
there are probably some particular
niches that it probably works better in
than others yeah what sort of use cases
is it good for like one of the big uses
is for time series data like user
analytics so if you have your
application just tracking like every
interaction people have on that thinking
Spotify is one of the big customers so
tracking every song that gets listened
to
and storing that in BigTable all those
listens and then having that data that
you can run different kinds of analytics
on and different kinds of machine
learning on you once you have all that
time series data then you can do so many
different things with it that you might
not be able to do with other databases
so running all kinds of analytics on it
doing different kinds of personalization
and you can do that all in real time
which you can't necessarily do
necessarily do with something like
bigquery where you can take those
queries and kind of run them ad hoc
BigTable kind of let you set that up to
be used in an application and maybe
create like a dashboard of all those
analytics or when you're training
machine learning you can train it
directly on the data in BigTable you
don't have to move it to somewhere that
can it can be accessed faster so all
those different pieces are why you might
want to use BigTable in adjacent to
something like bigquery so bigquery is
more like the warehouse kind of you go
and you make these queries they come
back you know usually pretty fast
seconds but that's still second whereas
BigTable you're placing it as a proper
database and you can treat it like one
and it works like one yeah exactly so
bigquery is your data warehouse you
might store the data in both locations
but you could give bigquery to your data
analysts and let them kind of run
queries over the entire data set or even
just play around with different data
sources but really if you're doing a
full table scan bigquery would be where
you'd want to go BigTable you're gonna
want to do different like pieces of that
so maybe like get me all the data for
this user and then do training on it or
display it on dashboard or something
like that and what is it about BigTable
that makes that like such a good fit
what can it do that makes it be able to
do that so well so one of the ways
BigTable is able to do all of this is
that it's a no sequel database and
because of that there's also no schema
so well there's one index which is just
on the row key so you define your row
key based on a few properties so let's
say you would set maybe a timestamp a
user ID in some kind of other categories
in that row key then you can only
perform a row get or a row range scan so
you'd say maybe get me all of the user
data for this user ID in this time range
and maybe for this genre or maybe for
all genres and it would depend on how
you organize those like segments of that
row key so it's basically just like a
concatenated string
of a few of those pieces of data so with
bigquery you really get that full sequel
interface and it's really easy to create
queries give it to the lucky some kind
of analyst with BigTable you really have
to think about how you're going to be
using it setting it up for specific
kinds of queries and once those are set
up those are the only kinds of queries
are gonna be able to run but they're
gonna be super fast so by putting a
little bit more it sounds like thought
into oh you're gonna be arranging
especially the keys but kind of how the
data is gonna be put into this database
that's how you're able to kind of keep
those really quick speeds up and that
huge scale yeah with big Taylor you're
getting sub 10 millisecond latency and
BigTable scales with notes I said it's
massively scalable so with each node you
get 10,000 QPS so you can just keep
adding more nodes so the typical the
typical minimum is three notes which is
30,000 QPS but you can really scale that
up until there aren't any more nodes
left like in all of Google's clouds
which is Google runs out of compute is
run out of computers that's endpoint
that's okay it's the cloud that's great
and just so I'm a hunter Sinclair as
well like I assuming you can do that
while things are alive as well I can
scale that up and down as my as my
throughput in my requirement like change
yeah so you can scale that up and down
it's not gonna be instantaneous because
some of the data needs to rearrange
itself for you to like see that benefit
I'm not totally sure how long it takes
but it's like not days it's a minute
definitely minutes yeah definitely in
that scale but back to kind of like
those row keys if those aren't
distributed evenly then you might run
into some kind of performance issues
right we've got a lot of documentation
and some code labs that walk you through
how to think about those row keys and
they're also a bunch of talks that we've
done at next showing sample row keys and
we've got this great tool called the row
key visualizer so you can maybe take a
subset of your data and a subset of your
queries when you're starting to plan out
what that schema might look like and see
are there any hotspots of data are there
any scans or doing a lot that don't look
great we have kind of a guide on what
query or what kind of imaging doesn't
look great so you can use that we've got
that tool to help you figure out what
schema in quotes
is gonna be best for your data and so
also like so we were talking about it
being like an OSI cool store as well so
you've got your key right so and that
could be looking at basically
concatenated string it sounds like yeah
and then your value we just dumping
Jason blobs in or like is there like a
binary protocol so we've got all of you
yeah so we've got column families and
column qualifiers so the families kind
of do some grouping on making it faster
if you're only clearing things from the
same column families on the column
qualifier some help you map to a
specific cell so you can just have a
bunch of cells with data and a cell is
identified by the row key the column
family and the column qualifier just
kind of we just shortcut that is the
column as well as a timestamp so you can
have multiple timestamps within each
cell so that can make it really good if
you want to use that for some part of
your time series management may be
saying store like an hour of data in
each cell or even just to have just
version tracking across the word but you
don't want to use that for your entire
time series because there's a limit to
how much data you can store per cell
so BigTable is a giant no sequel
database why would someone use BigTable
over you know setting up their own like
[ __ ] instance for example because the
BigTable is fully managed you're gonna
get the security and the reliability
that Google cloud is offering so like
we've offered however many nines of
reliability for a big table we have
replication as a feature so you can
distribute your data amongst the same
zone or we also have multi region
replication so you can really distribute
your data and take advantage of all like
the computing power that Google Cloud
has to offer Plus as the name implies I
hear it's big ya know I think you I
think you said something really
interesting there as well you were
talking about it where not only can we
do internal communication basically like
regional failover it sounds like we can
do global failover is that correct yes
you can set up to have multi region
replication so if you're kind of a
global business and want to have your
data store it across all different
regions so it's easier for you to access
you're gonna get that faster you're
gonna get lower latency to people trying
to access data within those regions so
it sounds like your data is essentially
mirrored or like you said replicated I
guess around the globe it's not just a
failover system
you're actually making sure you have
multiple copies yeah so you'd be able to
actually set up different application
profiles in terms of like where that
data might get access you can kind of
assess by that of your maybe customers
are in the u.s. you could have them go
towards the u.s. replication and access
data from that you can set it up in a
few different ways if you want to be
using the replications as a backup then
you can have those not get accessed at
all for any reads or writes and only use
that to store the data as a backup or
you can have it where you're
continuously interacting with both
instances of the replication it's gonna
be an eventual consistent system so you
might have some stale data that comes
back then it really just depends on your
use case it's a very flexible product so
really you need to figure out what parts
of it you're gonna use and how they
apply to your use case and turn all the
knobs specifically for that use case I'm
wondering here like he sounds like I
could probably do something like maybe
this kinds of rows that have this kind
of data maybe replicate that in one way
but these kinds of rows maybe don't is
would that be right or ORS I think it's
more of at least the table level it
might even be of the entire other things
I think it's of the entire instance
actually yeah but we can include the
replication Doc's in the show notes
absolutely so if you were gonna design a
system and had like your major you space
let's just say being in the US but you
wanted to still have lower read latency
for people across the globe if you were
then to spin up a major kind of writing
center in like let's say the APEC area
could there'd be like a multi master
scenario here or would everyone just be
writing to one and then replicating to
all these yeah there think there could
be multiple masters from what I know I
think that sounds ok I'd have to check
in the docs just to confirm so I can
head over to the open source side too
which is kind of interesting I know we
support like an HBase client can you
tell us about HBase is as well and just
like how all that works yeah so this is
kind of in the history of how BigTable
formed googles in using BigTable
internally for basically since the start
of Google all those that help our search
he'll try our Gmail and these like core
business products that we have and I
don't remember which year exactly but we
published a white paper that explained
what is BigTable basically how could
someone create it how we're using it and
the open source community took that
paper and created a CH
which is the open-source database
version of this basically and over time
some of these features have diverged
from what internal BigTable has to offer
and then a few years after we created
this white paper and HBase came out we
created cloud BigTable so when we
started with cloud BigTable we wanted to
make sure that people who are using HP
am used to it had an ability to just
take whatever they were using and just
just swap it directly out firm HBase -
BigTable so we support the HBase API so
anyone who's familiar with using HBase
should be able to just transfer their
stuff over pretty easily and use all the
API commands that they're used to and
not have to really change their code and
because of the open-source community
with HBase and because we have this
HBase client they're all these
open-source libraries that we get to use
for free with BigTable just because of
that compatibility so one of them is
Janus graph which does graph databases
there's open TS DB for time series and
gio mesa for geospatial data so it kind
of fits pretty well into the the cloud
like modularity model where you can take
these different pieces and swap them out
and this one happens to be a great
solution for a fully managed database on
the backend but in your application
wherever it is or whatever it is you can
theoretically swap this out and kind of
get all those benefits without having to
rewrite anything yeah yeah so it's
really nice for that but now many years
later I mean I know the last time you'll
had some talk about BigTable a while ago
2016 yeah so now we actually have nine
clients to use a big table we just came
out with a Java client so for people who
want to use a more idiomatic Java client
as with the other products we have
because they don't have their own like
spanner doesn't have an HBase or open
source equivalent apply it so now we're
using other products that we have you'll
be able to use kind of a very easy to
use Java client and we have Python go
it's all the silver languages that we
have to offer so here's an interesting
question then where do you think people
should choose using either the GCP
native clients or should they use the
HBase ones or like where does that promo
and call and kind of come from I think
it's just if you are using the HP's
clients already probably stick with the
HBase clients I know a lot of people
even before we came out with this Java
client had kind of created their own
Java clients and just found that easier
to work with so
we were like oh let's do that too so
like Greenfield use one of ours is
probably a bit of a nicer experience but
if you already have HBase and maybe go
with that instead yeah definitely and
you also mentioned you know earlier
we're talking about you know BigTable vs
bigquery and so you know there are very
different solutions despite sounding
somewhat similar yeah and then you just
mentioned spanner so if someone's coming
to this from a fresh perspective when is
a use case that you might use big table
or spanner or vice versa
yeah I think this is a very common point
of confusion because it really does
depend on your use case and Daniel Berg
face and I actually gave a talk on this
about specifically Internet of Things at
Google i/o so we should link that in the
description for more of the details but
for Internet of Things we kind of
realized that's like a very common use
case for all three of these types of
databases or data warehouses and I guess
what we were saying is if you have this
kind of time series data and you're
looking at these three solutions what
might be helpful to consider is
typically if you're just trying to do
something with a time series database go
with BigTable that kind of has all the
basics you need for a time series
database it's really fast
can scale and do all of that we also
looked a little bit at like datastore in
fire store and that's good at a smaller
scale with lower QPS and when you kind
of get into the scale of it with the big
table or with spanner you have to play
with it to figure that out and then for
spanner if you have transactions that's
really where if you're using a time
series database transactions are really
where you're gonna get the power of
using spanner over something like
BigTable and you also get the sequel
interface which is nice so that might be
part of the reason but typically it's
because of those transactions and with
spanner you're gonna get
I believe the rights are gonna be slower
with spanner just because of the way it
the data is replicated so they have to
write the data to all the locations that
the data is replicated before you can
read from it whereas BigTable because
it's eventually consistent you'll write
it and then you can read it right away
it just might not be there especially if
it's replicated yeah and then for
bigquery we couldn't have said think
about those databases totally separately
so if you're gonna choose datastore
firestore big table or spanner that's
one part of your solution and then
to use it a data warehouse that's kind
of like a totally separate part so for
that you'd use bigquery and like I said
where you do those ad hoc queries you
give that to a data analyst you can do
full table scans which aren't really
great for a spanner or BigTable that's
why you would use bigquery and like you
mentioned I mean you might have a system
in place where you use both BigTable and
bigquery at the same time yeah there's a
very close yeah so that's very common we
typically see people have like a data
flow job that writes to both at the same
time or even takes their data from
bigquery and writes it over to BigTable
or vice versa so what's the local
developer experience like with BigTable
do I have any like emulation tools or
anything like that that I can run
locally so that I can I can play with
this without having to spin up a bunch
of clusters in the cloud so we have a
big table emulator I haven't had a
chance to play with the to much so I
can't answer it is there though so we
have that yep and we also have so
BigTable nodes are fairly expensive I
think they're around like 600 650 I
don't want to say the exact number we
can look do it her node so typically you
do three notes for a production
environment so I can get pretty costly
per month I think although when I was
listening back to IANS podcast I think
it was triple that rate for one node so
that's at least great we've come down
the price but we do have a development
and since you can use so that's just one
node cool so that's a good way to
actually just play with it in the cloud
and actually get to use you're gonna
lose out on some of the power by only
having one node but you can really start
interacting with it and get a feel for
like the API and stuff so yeah I mean as
you said it's been a while since we
talked about it like what has changed in
the last two years with BigTable we got
like new cool stuff just more columns
and more keys well at the base BigTable
has stayed the same because I think it's
such like a foundational product it
can't really change too much but we've
added the replication we've added these
new clients and we also have this key
visualizer I think what's changed is the
environment around BigTable I mean GCP
has grown so much there's more if you
want to store stuff in BigTable the rest
of your ecosystem can comfortably be in
GCP and you're gonna find all those ways
you'd want to interact with BigTable
there so data
so jobs data proc even as some of the ML
features that we have Wien GCP so really
it's all about this environment that's
around big table you want big table
you're getting that low latency so you
don't want to have your stuff in
BigTable then be doing analytics on it
somewhere else
because then you're gonna lose some of
that low latency so getting to have an
ecosystem that supports BigTable and
supports everything around it I think
that's where GC has grown over the past
few years one of my favorite questions
what has been like the most interesting
thing you've seen someone do a BigTable
possibly weird or whacky one of the
things I really like is Spotify has
discover weekly so that happens on
BigTable and given a few talks about how
it works about their ecosystem and I
think they were saying before they had
BigTable they'd have like some engineers
like up all night trying to make sure
that their recommendation algorithm
wasn't going to crash or was going to be
available that like Monday morning for
those discovery weekly playlists and for
them to get onto BigTable and start
using them machine learning on that and
for have it to just be not something
they even have to worry about anymore
and could bring more recommendations in
different ways with that I think that's
just like such a cool thing that's
impacted my life one of the cool ways
I've got to play with BigTable was this
past GCP next or next 2019 we were kind
of figuring out what can we do to like
really try out like a real BigTable use
case play with it in a way that
developers might be playing with it so
we were like where can we find like a
cool internet of things or time series
database and we were poking around we
found this team called airView and
they've put air quality sensors in the
back of Google Street View cars and I've
been driving them around the Bay Area
and a few other cities so we contacted
them and started streaming some of that
data into big table through a dataflow
pipeline and then we're able to kind of
create like a real visualization with it
so that was cool just to see like oh if
you've got like an Internet of Things
and like a fleet of Internet of Things
how that process can be done and how you
could use that to kind of create a
real-time dashboard and do real
analytics on it and while we only had a
few cars it's cool to know like we could
easily just scale it up to like a
thousand cars or like ten thousand even
and just by adding more nodes
is there anywhere people should
specifically go if they want to learn
more about BigTable I would say go to
the BigTable documentation we've got
links to a lot of the talks we did at
necks would show off some of these
really cool use cases some of the
personalization some anti fraud the time
series analysis that talked at i/o about
how to choose your database I think with
BigTable you really want to know how
other people are using it so you can
learn about each knob and how to turn
them to best benefit you so before you
dive into any development with BigTable
learning a lot about it is probably the
best recommendation I'd have fantastic
and it sounds like that talk about
choosing the right database should be
super helpful too
because there are a lot of options out
there yeah and are you gonna be anywhere
and particularly going to any
conferences where people can come see
you talk I have nothing scheduled but if
anyone listening wants to hear more of
how BigTable sign me up
there you go and I'm sure you have a
Twitter account I assume I have a
Twitter account at Billy Jacobson there
we go we'll make sure we put that in the
show notes oh sure I find you as well
awesome
well Billy thank you so much for joining
us today until cru this old a big table
I think sir having me thanks so much to
Billy for coming in for talking about
big table I mean it's been a while
like I think we had mentioned you know
quite a number of episodes since big
tables last mentioned yeah but it's a
really really cool tool and I think
understanding what it's really good at
and how people can look at what's using
it as well as any future changes for it
I think really highlights exactly how
cool it is
ya know great interview thanks so much
for joining us Billy but let's get stuck
into our question of the week
so if I have an organization I've set up
an organization for my variety of GCD
projects and my projects are sort of
separated out by folder so I can manage
them in a coherent way it's easy to see
what's going on how do I break down my
billing data by folder so I can see
what's going on at that sort of folder
level right yeah I mean this is a really
important question for people who are
running an organization inside of GCP so
a lot of people who are just kind of
either individual users or hobbyists or
something like that can spin up Google
cloud platform with their personal
accounts and they can still set up a
billing account export that billing
account to bigquery and then you have a
actual like line-by-line more detailed
version of your billing data set so you
can write any analytics based on that or
you can do anywhere based on that but
when you're an organization maybe even
like a Macy's and your organization
structure is a little bit more
complicated you can create folders to
group your projects but when you export
that to bigquery you only have the IDS
of the folders not the actual names and
that can be a big challenge because you
know that I may not be looking for
folder one two five six seven three four
I'm looking for folder production and
development so Nick has written this
cool little article in a very very quick
tutorial to show you how to use the the
open source github project GCP folder
lookup which will basically take your
organization take your folders and put
that out to a bigquery table and then
you join that with your billing data set
to actually get a more detailed view now
all of your line items will actually
have the organization structure in them
as well so any analysis you're doing
with bigquery is a lot easier because
you can say okay we'll give me all the
costs and show me to me by this folder
or show it to me by this folder but only
for this specific GCP project oh no so
this creates like another table inside
your bigquery data structures so that
you can then like join that up based on
based on the ID of that table with that
is that right exactly yeah with the name
of the folder and then with the line
items that come through the bigquery
export it's way way more powerful and
you can see every single individual cost
over any time span as soon as you start
enabling the bigquery export of course
so it's a great way to either do data
analytics on your billing data or even
just to look up information you can also
plug it into data studio and you get a
nice cool visualization layer on top of
that
that's nice I'm just looking at here you
can both get like the parrot ever the
folder but also like what level and
stuff so if you have like semantic
reasoning behind which level your
folders are at you'll be like grab me
everything from level 2 you could do
some really neat stuff this way yep a
full view your organization so I think a
lot of people will be really excited to
be able to follow the instructions here
and like I said they're very quick and
then you'll have a lot more information
in your big query export very cool
awesome well before we finish up mark
are you producing any cool videos going
anywhere fancy like what are you up to
oh well I'll be headed to LA for a week
in a few weeks but in the meantime I
think it's mostly just working on videos
we are working with releasing some new
billing content you know very much in
line with our previous question and
talking a little bit more about how
people can understand the tools that are
available to them inside of the Google
cloud platform console so I'm super
excited to see those coming out probably
in the next couple weeks
very very cool how about yourself I'm
gonna shoot a little bit in the future
because there's some stuff I'm really
excited about so when this comes out on
Wednesday I'll be probably finished with
packs dev where I'd be doing two panels
but I'll be hanging around at PAX West
for the rest of the week so you know
eyes drop me a line if you're gonna be
there as well
later in the year I will be a cube con
in some capacity or another so I'm very
much looking forward to that and so one
thing else I also I want to talk about
it is next year but I'm very excited
about it Game Developers Conference next
year the big Game Developers Conference
essentially myself and Ed Pereira have
been working with games developers
conference to do a one-day summit at the
event basically Game Developers
Conference does a series of summits on
Mondays and Tuesdays about specific
topics and so online games technology
summit is what we're calling it
basically it's for anyone who works in
like backend systems for online games
anyone who works on like client-server
networking basically anything to do with
multiplayer online connected games
anything in that capacity infrastructure
management scaling security monitoring
all that kind of stuff there really
isn't a space for us people who work in
that to really gather and do stuff so
see if people open on the 29th of August
so after this comes out so if you're
looking to attend or possibly submit you
know put it in your calendar now and get
it done
really excited about it and very happy
for working with GDC on this initiative
so I got very excited about this yeah
it's super cool I know you've been
talking about working with them for a
little while so it's really exciting to
see it come to fruition
think like you said this isn't a space
that exists right now there's not a lot
of people talking about this so having
kind of a conference for all these
people to get together and talk about
these technologies I think will
ultimately help the information sharing
aspect of it that's the idea trying to
try to help grow this particular part of
the industry
but anyway it's good good stuff well
it'll be a lot of fun and I'm sure a lot
of people are super excited to hear
about it as well I hope so that's the
plan all right mark well thanks so much
for joining us this week and we'll talk
to you all soon see you all next week
[Music]
coming to you live from New York City in
San Francisco in San Fran not live and
not live we're just lying to everybody
there we go